well no doubt about it this year has
been hard for students and teachers but
tonight we want to celebrate one teacher
whose work is
making a difference in the world of
distance learning as sasha loftis
explains she received a very special
honor for her efforts right here in
clark county
i'm just so honored to even
be recognized by this at all kristin
polisky dedicates her days
to love and learning i knew from second
grade when i was in second grade that i
wanted to be a teacher
she's a kindergarten teacher at shirley
barber elementary school
that goes above and beyond to help her
kids succeed
even through the covid 19 pandemic
learning
never ends there's always time to teach
and there's always these teachable
moments
the transition hasn't been easy but her
determination hasn't wavered
and one student's family took notice
they nominated her
for the juicy juice 100 percent thankful
teacher contest
and she was one of five first prize
winners in the country
i just didn't think that this
something like this could happen and so
it was just a very
it was a very humbling moment kristin
hopes this recognition
helps all teachers realize the real
impact
their work has on the world none of us
go into this job
for the money we don't go into it for
the recognition we just want to
we just want to help help kids learn and
and achieve
great things sasha loftus 8 news now
by the way kristin was the only local
teacher to be nominated this year and as
a first place winner she also received a
thousand dollar gift card to michael's
chances are pretty high she's going to
spend that on her kids